how's it going everybody
so yesterday Benedict Wang was at Fan
Expo in Vancouver and during a panel he
talked about Avengers for the filming
that he's done so far and then he
dropped a bomb on us about Doctor
Strange too I'm still giving away copies
of infinity war and ant-man and the wasp
and some special edition posters all you
have to do to enter the giveaway is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero so during the
panel long of course confirmed that he
has shot scenes for Avengers 4 and he's
even gone back to do some reshoots
recently of course he gave nothing away
he didn't even say if his character
survived the snap or not so we don't
really know his role in Avengers 4
however a recent trailer description
leaked has told us that he has in fact
survived the snap and he is
communicating with Doctor Strange in the
soul world so if this turns out to be
true he does have somewhat of a major
important role in Avengers 4 and like he
said he has film scenes and he's even
done reshoots but on top of the talk
about Avengers 4 he also went on to talk
about Doctor Strange too long hit
everybody with a huge surprise when he
said that he expects to start filming
for Doctor Strange 2 this December this
puts the film's production way ahead of
schedule they were originally supposed
to start filming several months into
2019 however guardians of the galaxy 3
is put on hold indefinitely and it was
supposed to begin production in early
2019 and supposed to come out in 2020
but obviously that is not the case now
and Marvel actually doesn't have another
movie scheduled until 2020 after
spider-man far from home comes out in
July of 2019 so there is a pretty big
gap and it seems like they may be trying
to fill it with Doctor Strange too which
is why that they're pushing a production
one thing that this does reveal to us is
that clearly Doctor Strange and Wong
survived the events of Avengers 4 this
is just more proof that those who got
wiped away from Thanos his snap will
somehow be coming back at some point in
time in Avengers 4 so let me know what
you all think about this awesome news of
Doctor Strange coming to theaters a lot
sooner than expected leave your thoughts
in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe comment
and like this video so you can enter my
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything related to Avengers 4 and
Doctor Strange - as always thank you so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]